pour l'afrique du sud un des meilleurs
systèmes de santé du continent les 60 %
des sud-africains vivent dans une
pauvreté extrême
impossible ici comme dans la majorité
des pays africains d'imposer un
confinement sans donner de l'eau et de
la nourriture
ces rations dit ils seront épuisés dans
deux semaines le reste du mois je vais
devoir quêter pour de la nourriture
parce que je n'ai pas d'emploi
jusqu'ici l'afrique du sud et l'algérie
sont les plus durement frappés les deux
pays ont un nombre semblable de cas
autour de 2000 mais l'algérie a beaucoup
plus de victimes avec près de 300 décès
des milliers d'algériens ont réagi en
devenant bénévole
ces étudiants confectionne de
l'équipement de protection pour le
personnel de la santé allez je suis venu
pour aider dit elle pour que nous soyons
aux côtés du pays et du personnel
médical qui veillent sur nous 24 heures
sur 24
[Musique]
au burundi les églises étaient bondées
dimanche pour la messe de pâques on
célébrons c'est lui qui a le pouvoir et
la force de dieu lui même ceux qui sont
malades des rassemblements religieux
semblables ont provoqué une accélération
spectaculaire de la contagion dans
plusieurs régions du monde au sénégal
ils ont été interdites aux en mars
l'interdiction l'effectif dirige la
lutte contre le coronavirus au sénégal
qui a moins de 300 cas et seulement deux
décès selon lui la contagion demeure
faible car la population est très jeune
les frontières et les écoles ont été
fermées tôt et rassemblements interdits
et que tous les cas suspects sont testés
et soigner rapidement
messieurs les cas se multiplient par
milliers cette prise en charge ne sera
plus possible dit il
en france en italie aux états-unis dans
tous ces pays ils ont été débordés
quand il ya eu des dizaines de milliers
de cas est évidente en argot risque de
l'auto le confinement n'est pas
généralisée au sénégal les usines et les
marchés sont encore ouverts on encourage
donc fortement le port de masques en
public
mais comme partout ailleurs au manque de
matériel ici au sénégal est un art nous
devrons de synovate chez un
professionnel en propre à prendre
et justement une équipe d'ingénieurs
sénégalais viennent de développer ce
respirateur qu'ils pourront fabriquer
sur place avec des imprimantes 3d nous
ont fait rire les spectateurs qui va
faire la même chose
la même fonction à un coût beaucoup
beaucoup moins important malgré
l'engagement de millions de bénévoles
dans la guerre contre le virus
si l'explosion de cas se réalise
les frites manquera cruellement de
moyens et de personnel soignant n'a fait
que aussi pause pendant moins de
ressources humaines on a moins de moyens
financiers on a moins de sens de cette
année donc c'est tout à fait logique
c'est dire que ce qui se passe aux
états-unis en a fait selon l'onu la
crise économique provoquée par
l'épidémie sera encore plus dévastatrice
en afrique
que le corona virus se fit vous étiez au
sénégal au début de l'épidémie la coved
elle a l'air de se propager très
lentement là bas et ailleurs en afrique
d'ailleurs mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ça céline ça c'est le
grand mystère de cet ennemi de cette
épidémie
pour beaucoup d'experts et le cas du
sénégal et particulièrement
exceptionnelle j'étais là-bas durant la
relâche scolaire et dès le 4 mars
on a interdit les rassemblements vous
savez à ce moment là le sénégal et le
québec avec quelques cas confirmés mais
la propagation a été beaucoup beaucoup
plus rapide au québec
alors on peut regarder les chiffres au
13 mars le québec avait dix sept cas
confirmés le sénégal 11
un mois plus tard le kiné le québec
compte maintenant près de 3500 cas et
360 décès le sénégal est encore à 291
cas et seulement deux décès alors
beaucoup doutent de la fiabilité des
données en afrique mais au sénégal
les tests sont faits par l'institut
pasteur qui a une excellente réputation
donc ces données là sont fiables
bien sûr il ya des malades qui vont
mourir avant de se rendre à l'hôpital
donc ils ne seront pas testés ils ne
feront pas partie des statistiques
même si on gonfle les chiffres au
sénégal ça reste très très très loin du
bilan québécois et il ya une thèse
plausible c'est que la transmission
communautaire n'aurait pas encore fait
en afrique les ravages que ça fait dans
nos pays
alors on espère que ça va rester comme
ça merci beaucoup sophie je vous en prie